et j'explore comment je peux le transformer.
J'ai travaillé chez Philips Electronics
dans le labo de recherche de design futuriste,
en me projetant 20 ans dans le futur.
J'ai exploré la peau humaine
et la transformation du corps par la technologie.
J'ai travaillé sur des concepts comme un tatouage électronique,
qui est augmenté par le toucher,
ou des robes que rougissaient et tremblaient à la lumière.
J'ai commencé mes propres expériences.
Ce sont les approches low-tech des conversations high-tech que j’avais.
J'ai collé des cotons-tiges sur mon colocataire
avec de la colle à perruque.
(Rires)
J'ai commencé une collaboration avec un ami à moi, Bart Hess,
(en temps normal, il ne ressemble pas à ça)
et nous nous sommes servis de nous-mêmes comme modèles.
Nous avons transformé nos appartements en laboratoires
et avons travaillé de façon très spontanée et immédiate.
(Rires)
Nous étions en train de créer des images défiant l'évolution humaine.
Alors que j'étais chez Philips,
on a discuté de l'idée d'une technologie du peut-être,
quelque chose qui n'était ni allumé ni éteint, mais entre les deux,
qui peut-être pourrait être gazeux ou liquide.
Et je suis devenue obsédée par l'idée de brouiller le périmètre du corps
pour qu'on ne puisse plus voir où finit la peau
et où commence l'environnement proche.
J'ai créé mon studio dans le quartier des prostituées
et me suis enveloppée moi-même
dans des tuyaux de plomberie de manière obsessionnelle,
j'ai trouvé une façon de redéfinir la peau
et de créer ce textile dynamique.
On m'a présenté Robyn, la pop star suédoise,
et elle explorait aussi
comment la technologie coexiste avec l'émotion humaine brute.
Elle a parlé de la technologie, avec ces nouvelles plumes,
ce nouveau maquillage, ce punk,
comment nous nous identifions au monde, et nous avons fait ce clip.
Je suis fasciné par l'idée
de ce qu'il se passe lorsqu'on fusionne la biologie avec la technologie,
et je me souviens avoir lu l'idée de pouvoir reprogrammer la biologie
dans l'avenir, loin de la maladie et du vieillissement.
J'ai pensé à ce concept :
imaginez si on pouvait reprogrammer notre propre odeur corporelle,
la modifier, et l'améliorer sur le plan biologique.
et de comment ça changerait notre façon de communiquer.
Ou la façon dont nous attirons des partenaires sexuels ?
Reviendrait-on à être plus comme des animaux,
à des modes de communication plus primaires ?
J'ai travaillé avec un biologiste synthétique
et j'ai créé un parfum qu'on peut avaler,
qui est une pilule cosmétique que vous mangez
et le parfum sort par la peau lorsque vous transpirez.
Ça déconstruit complètement ce qu'est le parfum,
et offre un tout nouveau format.
C'est le parfum qui va de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur.
Ça redéfinit le rôle de la peau, et nos corps deviennent un atomiseur.
J'ai appris qu'il n'y a pas de limites :
si je regarde l'évolution de mon travail,
je vois des fils et des connexions qui ont du sens.
Mais quand je regarde vers l'avenir,
le prochain projet est complètement inconnu et grand ouvert.
J'ai l'impression que toutes ces idées sont intégrées à l'intérieur de moi
et ce sont ces expériences et ces conversations
qui relient ces idées, et elles sortent de façon instinctive.
En tant qu'architecte du corps, j'ai créé cette plateforme
sans limites et sans bornes
pour me permettre de découvrir tout ce que je veux.
Et j'ai l'impression que j'ai à peine commencé.
Voici donc une journée ordinaire au bureau.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Merci !